now then dame vivienne westwood's
clothes have been worn by well everyone
really celebrities rock stars and
politicians while her political beliefs
have backed once the Labour Party the
Conservative Party and most recently the
Green Party and after decades at the
forefront of fashion the queen of punk
has published her memoirs in da reform
joins me now from the Chapman festival
not a very good morning to you dame
vivienne very good to see you now I hear
you want to start with a message for us
hello listen I can't hear very well
because I'm going deaf but I've got a
message and the message is in this book
these diaries and that's why I'm here to
tell this message but I've also got the
solution which isn't in the book hadn't
worked it out at that point and I really
like to tell you what it is this message
so I'm going to go right ahead which is
that our problem you know I care about
climate change it means mass extinction
very soon unless we do something about
it everybody knows this and so this is
the message that the world is controlled
by 1 million people control 7 billion we
all know who the 7 billion are and the 1
million is this it is the bank's the big
conglomerate monopolies like Monsanto
and shell and it is the politicians who
serve them this is the 1 million people
and they do it the power they have is
through the rotten financial system they
control everybody through the rotten
financial system through austerity and
through siphoning off the profits at the
other end this is what is killing us
it's also causing climate change and
there's a way out of it the thing is the
same people are always in power you know
think about voting you might as well it
doesn't matter who you vote for they're
all the same their power driven their
auntie people they're killing us and
there is a solution because what we
think is
but there is no opposition and there is
amazing opposition and it's you the
viewer and we could come our enemy is
the rotten financial system and what
we've got to do is get a green economy
and that will solve everything and the
way you do it you do it now today is all
you've got to do is change to green
energy it's cheaper than the normal
energy and normal energies its fossil
fuel energy is heavily heavily
subsidized by the taxpayer the more
people join and have free cheap electric
cheap electricity the more cheap it will
become and it will save the world you
can save the world by turning it into a
green economy it's very very simple
please save us we've all got to help
this is my message that is the solution
change to green energy this already
twenty percent of the country does it if
you imagine it would change everything
it would change all the fossil fuel
industry all the death everything it
would give us freedom but you say dame
vivienne your enemy is the status quo
we've heard it volubly there you know
there are people listening to you right
now saying but vivienne westwood now is
the status quo she's a dame she runs a
company that makes millions of millions
of pounds who charges hundreds and
thousands of pounds for her products all
I can say is its value for money I think
my company's accompanied for the future
by less choose well make it last it's
not cheap labor it's labor intensive
it's skilled people are happy doing it
it's quality not quantity this is how we
save the world and buy less but you can
even even though all those people who
come up with all these plastic bags full
of landfill that they where you could
you could get one thing from me in the
sale it would last you
well Davion you used to think you say
the answer is not now in the political
parties but you used to think that
didn't you you I mean you've been a
member or helped out at various times
the Conservatives the Labour Party and
now the Greens do you think action now
lies in a different form perhaps on the
streets listen you know I can't hear you
very well but I know you're talking
about politics and this is the way to
control our politics for people this is
what I'm talking about it's completely a
very few people are in charge of 7
billion and the 7 billion don't have any
power but i'm telling you you do have
power and and so it's not about voting
it's about letting theresa may know that
there is a big focus of opposition in
this country most people are opposed to
what the government does but they don't
have any way to express this opposition
and i'm giving you a way to express your
opposition and to have more power than
Theresa May has this one telling you
it's not about voting but by all means
you know I always vote for the Green
Party because up until now there was
nobody else to vote for but we've got
Jeremy Corbyn and we've got the Scottish
nationalists and I hope they're more
inclined to be green than the others who
are nothing to do with it the fossil
fuel industry is incredibly heavily
subsidized by the taxpayer and also by
austerity because the poor get poor
poorer in order that the the subsidy can
be given to the fossil fuel industry so
just go cheap and it gets cheaper and
cheaper well dame vivienne thank you
very much a dude on the people we got
the message thank you very much deed and
a very sorry had a bit of trouble
hearing us and the solution we got it
dame vivienne thank you very much indeed
and there she's off on a lovely day in
Cheltenham dame vivienne westwood at the
Cheltenham literary festival her die
is out now called get her life whew